contrairement aux apparences ces
motocyclistes de la police nationale
n'effectue pas un contrôle ce samedi au
chesnay ils ont donné rendez vous aux
motards yvelinois pour une journée
d'ateliers pédagogiques
objectif de ce premier parcours piste de
la journée revoir les bases de la
conduite du dos rond ça permet de voir
que tous les défauts que l'on à quoi ça
permet de les corriger
je pense que oui ça peut ça peut sauver
des vies si on connaît bien la machine
avec ses ateliers gratuits la police
espère corriger les comportements
davantage responsables des accidents
mortels que l'alcool ou la vitesse
l'objectif c'est de le faire que les
participants le fasse avec leurs propres
photos persos de façon à mieux connaître
eux aussi leur moto ça peut lors d'un
événement particulier
la conduite est vite et éventuellement
justement un accident en ayant des
mauvais réflexe due à des mauvais
réflexion
ils ont aussi plus le même regard sur
leur propre conduite et celle des autres
autre atelier proposé le secourisme les
participants apprennent à gérer une
situation
tristement courante les gestes à
connaître face à une personne accidentée
il ya très peu de pourcentage de la
population qui a passé le pc qui se
connaît les gestes de secourisme donc
c'est plus qu'utile et on se rend compte
que si les gens connaissent si les gens
savent bail en posant tout simplement
sauver des vies les gendarmes et les crs
se sont associés à la police pour cette
journée de prévention ludique dont le
but est avant tout de lutter contre
l'insécurité routière en 2017 40000
personnes dont quatorze motards ont
perdu la vie sur les routes des yvelines